joe ross looking for his first career
win against la five games three starts a
540 era oh and two swing
and a miss to start off the holiday
swing and a miss
two good hitters two swinging strikeouts
upstairs you talk about establishing the
fastball early
three swinging strikeouts for joe ross
first start by clementine against the
dance out of the dodger bullpen castro
rams one out to right center that's
gonna plug the gap as he continues his
outstanding hitting to the other side of
the field
runners go with the payoff pitch
he got him
97 passed him he struck him out strands
two one hit for the nets we go to the
second no score on the fourth of july
soto says hello to the lefty
something
or somebody called that from the dugout
because about halfway down to first base
juan soto looked over his right shoulder
right back at his skipper or maybe his
hitting coach
they probably said hey look for that
first pitch slider
and that's what he got hit off the end
of the back but
ball is laced in the air which is so
important for juan soto
let's see who he's looking at in the
dugout
looks like davey
it's a big spot now for starving castro
and they're still leaving the right side
of the infield open except for muncie
and another opposite field hit how well
did harrison read it really well he
scores soto to third the knacks are on
top
joe ross has struck out six through
three he's
scattered a couple of base hits baby a
strikeout victim in his first at-bat
batting third today
and baby spanx won the left center field
a long run and gone a home run
robles kept running and running ran out
of room beatty goes the other way with
his fourth home run of the year and ties
the score at 1.
this time in 1776 it was actually voted
on by congress on july 2nd
that is going to get down for the base
hit right in front of roblox
history on with a two hot single
two odds runner at first pitch deluxe
and he goes the other way and that's
down for basic
looking rush for the single and the
dodgers are back-to-back base hits
with two down
oh
that sounded like helmet
thankfully for barnes a glancing blow
trainer manager coming out
thankfully he turned
his back to the plate
always a scary moment anytime you see
this here
sinker just gets away from joe a little
bit
but you can see austin barnes turned his
head the correct way
see look on starland's face nobody wants
to see that
and he got him up in the zone again
and steven souza jr giving it to mike
estabrook
ross's biggest pitch of the game
the dodgers had already scored dave
roberts out of the dunk out in case he
needed to protect his guy from being
thrown out but the pitch hitter is gone
and so are the dodgers in the fourth
then rush is potters won by taylor wow
94. great location
and that's number nine
for joe russ
2-2 from joe ross
number 10
a season high and joe ross so efficient
the last two innings on only 21 pitches
so he's doing what davey desperately
needed him to do today pitch deep
and he lifts this one in the air
left center field on the run his baby
won't get it
[Applause]
bell on his way to second here comes the
throw and he's out
he lost contact with the bag chris
taylor kept contact with the glove and
bell
is out
it was great effort by beatty out there
in left field
and then he does a good job getting up
quickly
finding the ball and getting it in
and then chris taylor doing a great job
with the tags
great effort just out of reach recognize
the ball
picks it up
good throw to second
does get that hand in there i was
wondering if he got him before he got
the hand on it but
don't assume anything chris taylor
stayed with it so he was definitely safe
and it was once he slid by the bag
[Music]
what a good at bat
and that's going to plug the gap out of
right center
escobar two for three today and as in
that
he's three for seven
willa called that a two-game hitting
streak since his return to the big
leagues
good stuff right there welleski's fourth
career first for the nats and fourth
career double against david price
one two to roblox
decent inning for price he does give up
two hits but no runs and they leave a
man in scoring position
ross with 11 strikeouts no walks no
national starting pitcher this season
has had 10 or more strikeouts and zero
walks in the game
one two
left and down the three this will get
lux home and the dodgers will take the
lead
and pujols will stop at first
but he's now driven into running four
straight
and the dodgers lead for the first time
today albert
with a pinch-hit rbi single
so joe ross still responsible for the
runner at first the pinch runner tony
gonzalon running for albert pujols who
drove in the go ahead run lux had the
lead off double to get the ending going
her ball this one is smashed into right
center field that ball is going to go to
the wall
godzilla on his horse
and he's sprinting like a cat around
third base and he is in to score it is
three to one dodgers
first pitch base hit tris barrero
[Applause]
that's his first big league hit and he
wants to make sure it doesn't go in the
ball bucket and goes on his mantle
as i mentioned a couple of years ago
over two isn't that
over four this year before that now we
got some baby shark action coming in
a great swing on a bowling ball sinker
dan mentioned
lacy getting in the four hole
[Music]
this is playable for
bellinger
falls off pollock he makes the catch
inning is over
and we're on to the eighth at nationals
park dodgers three washington one
and he hits this one of the right center
a base hit
lux with a three-hit game
these guys do have microphones in their
helmets they can hear us
and turner is hit and down he goes
dave roberts sprinting out of the dugout
trainer right behind him
and all three of them are going to walk
down the first page line he's starting
to see this way too often bob
it's very scary
i think similar to austin barnes
he's
just able to turn his head just in time
max muncie likes these situations
ball no strikes to muncie
the fly ball to center field retreating
his para at the wall it's over his head
and off the wall as para crashes into
the wall
luck scores
barnes scores
and turner scores a three-run double for
max spuncy and the dodgers have blown it
open it is six to wasp five to one not
six to one turner did not score
and he tried the breaking ball this time
and he gets the ground ball to rucks
there's one there's two game over
the dodgers have won nine in a row a 5-1
winner today over washington
they played washington seven times this
season they have beaten them all seven
times